Hey, I’m Dean Peterson, a filmmaker from
Brooklyn, NY.
I made the film INCREDIBLY SMALL and I’m
about to shoot my second feature film WHAT
CHILDREN DO.
When we shot my first film, we shot it on
the SONY EX1 camera and we used old Nikon
prime lenses with a Letus adapter, which gave
it a really great image.
The old Nikon lenses mixed with the spinning
glass and the Letus adapter gave it this smooth,
creamy, filmic feel, which we really liked.
We chose that camera partly because my DP
owned it, but also partly because back in
2009 when we shot the movie, DSLR cameras
were not really a mainstay of the industry
yet.
The Canon 5D hadn’t even been out for a
year and films like TINY FURNITURE, which
opened the door for using these DSLRS, hadn’t
even come out yet.
So we had limited options.
Back then people were still using the traditional
camcorders like the HVX’s a lot.
We just used what we had.
The change we made from the first movie until
we made the second is incredible in terms
of cameras.
Now you can go to Best Buy and purchase a
$700 DSLR that shoots 4K and you can shoot
in pitch black, whereas back then is simply
wasn’t the case.
There was still a lot of limitations.
It was a completely different landscape back
then (2009 and prior).
The decision of what were going to shoot on
this time was a lot more involved and we had
a lot more options and research to do.
We talked about what we wanted the image to
look like for this film and we also talked
about process.
We are going to be a very small, nimble crew
and we’re going to be shooting very quickly
and we didn’t want to deal with a lot of
peripheral accessories that you needed to
add on to the camera.
We didn’t want a camera that necessitated
a huge camera department.
We wanted to be as agile and adaptable as
we possibly could.
My DP Darren and I had shot a film on the
Black Magic (cinema camera) and we really
liked how that looked.
We liked that the Pocket cinema camera is
small and looks great, but you have to add
all this stuff to the camera.
The battery kind of “sucks.”
You have to have an external power source.
It’s hard to do hand-held stuff with such
a small camera, so you end up putting it in
a cage and a shoulder rig.
So by the end of adding all this stuff and
complications, it’s kind of as big and as
expensive as all these other cameras.
The camera that we finally decided to shoot
on was the Canon C300.
I shot a music video on it before and I loved
the way it looks.
I feel like it takes all of the barriers out
of the way when you’re shooting.
I feel like it’s easy to get a great image
quality out of it.
The ‘Low-Light’ is incredible.
You can go into locations and not need to
light them too much, which is a big part of
how we are going to shoot this movie – we
are going to go into a lot of rooms and businesses
and try to use as much natural/available light
as possible.
The Canon C300 is the best kind of camera
I’ve ever used for that kind of shooting.
I do find myself going online and falling
to the hysteria of camera culture that exists
on there.
And it’s always these camera comparison
tests of like guys shooting the side of their
house or the blowing of leaves in their back
yard to show the muddled compression of one
camera versus another.
At that point, I find it good to step back
and just remind yourself that at the end
of the day we’re supposed to be storytellers.
These cameras, tools and technology that we
use are just supposed to be there in service
of telling a story and not as a cool toy to
have.
Even thought I do find it shockingly easy
to get swept up in the debate of how many
stops of dynamic range something has, what
is the best codec, what bitrates this kind
of camera has, it is always best to remind
myself that at the end of the day these are
not the most important things.
It is definitely important, but it’s not
the most important consideration when you’re
making a movie.